what what has been the most
rewarding thing for you for being santa
for this many years
well you know i've been very lucky to do
a lot of events with celebrities and
i've done tv and film and things like
that but
i think one of the important things is
to be grounded to be
you know know the base uh of what we do
with santa
and as i said earlier the number one
rule is the children
and volunteer work with the children i i
like i said at 4 500 santas and i
surveyed them and interviewed them and
uh
you know all of them do volunteer work
uh all over you know whether it's local
church work
school working fact a lot of times they
actually got started
because someone came to him saying would
you volunteer to do something for the
school
or the church or something like that so
the volunteer work is important
and i truly enjoy doing work with
children's hospitals in fact this year
i'll be doing a lot with hasselfeld
children's hospital in new york city
but i've done things with the ronald
mcdonald house and
i'm also the national santa for the
marine corps toys for tots
so i get to do a lot of volunteer work
uh we've done airlifts of toys
into uh areas that have been impacted by
hurricanes
natural disasters and so those are
the emotions you have with the families
and children
are very very special and when uh uh you
know children give me a hug all the time
you know
except this year of course but when it's
in it
when it's one of these special
situations where the family wasn't
expecting anything and you get that hug
and you see their face you know
i remember on dr phil we had a whole
bunch of children
after hurricane katrina and he brought
them all to hollywood and well actually
they were all in hollywood
uh living in southern california because
different churches had
brought them in and were helping them
while
uh their families were trying to get
resettled
and all of these families uh were
brought to
the paramount studios and they had a big
event and afterwards the children were
brought into an area where
they had filled the entire street with
toys
every type of toy you could think of and
dr phil
the the gates were closed and doctor
bill said okay we open the gates
it says you get one of every toy you see
and they open the gates of the kids ran
in
and i'm sitting there doing my homes and
having every time
but about 10 minutes in i'm standing
with some of the parents and the parents
are just
crying because they didn't expect
anything
they were wondering what they were going
to do for their children this year
and now their children had just
saw that santa opened his toy bag thank
you dr phil
and uh but again i'm sitting there
watering up when that happened so it's
it's those types of things i think that
give me a good base to work from
then i get to do the fancy stuff too you
know
would you say that's also the
characteristics of the
4 500 some santas that you've trained
that they have to have a heart for this
i think well again uh you have to be
real and we tell them that in the school
you know
you are santa and your job is to to
uh number one job is is the children and
you're there to serve the children
and to be santa to them and to answer
all their questions and
take care of all their uh and you can't
always give them the exact answer
they want but you have to listen to them
and you have to give them
uh hopefully some optimistic outlook
how do you do that in this season
it is hard you know the children are
wondering how we're going to get to the
house the parents are actually wondering
how do they
help their child get the letter to santa
so that santa can
uh you know respond to them um
the marine corps toys for tots during
spring months actually distributed like
three million
toys uh to children and families saw
around the country in areas that were
highly impacted and where the children
were
you know you're just you know it's
terrible you're stuck at home the
parents are stuck at home and
uh you know the parents don't have jobs
and it's just really rough
isn't it great to get the kids some
games or some books
keep their minds occupied and that's
something that
the marine corps did they have a little
side
thing that they do with the literacy uh
program
and so that's what they did they used
the books and the games for the kids
and this christmas uh we'll be doing
some airlifts i think we're gonna do one
in puerto rico and some other areas of
the country
unfortunately uh uh santa is a civilian
and so i can't go on some of these
military flights
to uh to be with the children and
families but the marines will get the
toys to them
and help them have a little better
[Music]
christmas